yeah we're talking about a problem
involving putting numbers into boxes and
other shapes and the shape is an
arrangement of boxes that looks
something like this and I've got a
certain number of boxes in the first row
so I have four boxes in the first row
and and two in the second row and one in
the third row and the rule is that these
numbers must be decreasing and the
second rule is that the boxes are left
justified and that's it that's the rule
simple example would be this here's a
bus square three boxes in the first row
three in the second row and three in the
third row so the number of box isn't it
and two rows can be the same another
example of a shape would be something
like this this is something we call a
staircase four and three and two and one
other shape that's kind of interesting
it turns out for my purposes is where I
have two rows of the same length this
would be the shape six six well we put
numbers in them and so maybe I can even
do it with these shapes and show you
exactly what we do so in this first
shape we have seven boxes altogether so
I take the numbers 1 1 2 7 the rules are
that the numbers must be increasing
along rows and increasing down columns
so 1 3 6 is increasing 2 5 is increasing
and so forth that's those are the rules
this is called a standard young tableau
young as a person yes that's right well
I'm at it the word tableau it just
simply means an arrangement of numbers
in a shape with no rules satisfying them
so for example I can just do an example
of a tableau that's not a standard young
tableau of what the one here and it 2
here and the 3 here and the 4 here and
the 5 and the 6 and the 7 so these
numbers are not increasing along rows
and increasing down columns so that's
just called a tableau and we're going to
talk today about standard young tableau
here I'll make a standard tableau and
actually while I make it it's sort of
important to understand what I'm doing
while I'm making it because I have to
put a 1 in the upper left-hand corner
there's no choice about that and then 2
has to go either here or here I'll put
it there 3 has to go either here or here
at that point I'll put it down here
maybe 4 here 5 here and if I stop before
I'm finished you can see that what's
happening is that I'm building the shape
the shape is the 3x3 square but I'm
building it up cell by cell
in terms of what I'm getting is a
sequence of sub shapes so right now what
I've done I've created a tableau of this
shape but I'll finish it up now so four
five six seven eight nine so that's a
standard tableau of that shape I'll do
one here quickly one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten and here one
two three four five six seven twelve
it's easy to do it because you just sort
of build your way from the upper
left-hand corner down to the bottom
right-hand corner in this case oh well
that's a good question because what I
really want to talk about is how many
there are the problem of computing the
number of standard tableau what's kind
of amazing is that we know very exact
and precise answers to that question so
I'll tell you for example let's take
this shape the number of standard young
tableau I'll abbreviated SC is YT is 42
so I could systematically write down all
42 tableau and I would I could convince
myself that I was correct but there's a
formula for it and the formula goes like
this and I'll show you how you do it
is equal to let's say there's nine cells
in this shape so it's 9 times 8 times 7
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 divided by this 9 factorial and
by the way that's the number of ways of
just filling this shape with the numbers
in any manner whatsoever so the total
number of fillings of this of this shape
which is what we've called a tableau is
9 factorial it's this very large number
because there's nine choices for what to
put here and eight for what to put there
once you've decided on the first one and
seven for what you what to put here once
you've decided on these two etc so you
get nine factorial quite easily but if
you require the rules to be satisfied
then the number has to be reduced by
something and I'm going to tell you
exactly what it has to be reduced by
first we take this shape and we fill
them up with a bunch of other numbers
and we then the numbers are constructed
this way I put a 1
here and then a 2 and then a 3 and then
I go up 4 and then 5 and then I go down
4 and then 3 and then down 2 and then up
3 and I divide this by those number by
the product of all those numbers and the
ratio of these two numbers is the number
of standard young tableau of this shape
now let's just compute it say this
cancels this cancels these cancel 5
cancels 4 cancels 3 times 2 is 6 4
cancels leaving 2 3 cancels leaving 3
I've cancelled everything and I say 3
times 2 times 7 which is 42 so that's
how I got 42 no the question is these
numbers that's the question the big
question is well there are two there are
two questions one where did these
numbers come from they just came out of
the blue what's going on and secondly
why is it true and why is it true
generally so what's going to happen is
that not only am I going to well have
shown you a formula for computing
standard tableau of shapes like this but
it's going to work for any shape so I
have to tell you what these numbers are
and these numbers are called the hook
numbers hook numbers are the following
you have a shape I'll do it sort of
schematically first every cell has a
hook number you can see for example here
every cell had a hook number how did I
get this hook number the answer is that
I first of all computed the hook
associated with that cell and the hook
is everything that you get by going down
from it and to the end to the right and
and the square itself so you get this
sort of l-shaped inverted l-shape thing
which we call a hook so that's the hook
associated with that cell and so for
example we can take this cell here
what's its hook number well it's hook
consists of everything to the right and
everything below and so there are three
cells all together so the hook number is
three this has hook number four since
because I have 1 2 3 4 this ends up
number 5 so I had 1 2 3 4 5 etc so
that's what I was doing when I when I
went through that crazy process of
filling the square up with
I was computing the hook numbers
actually so the main result now is that
for any shape the kinds of shapes I was
telling you about before not just the
special square shapes the formula is
exactly this you take the n factorial
where n is the number of cells invited
by the product of all the hook numbers
all right so let's let's do one more
example who here is the shape that's a
four-to-one shape yes exactly
well first of all n is 7 so the number
of standard young tableau is going to be
7 times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 divided by the product of the
hook lengths and so what are they I'm
gonna start putting the hook lengths in
each cell this is what we call a corner
cell maybe I should use that term now
because it's going to come up again it's
it's a cell with hook length 1 it's hook
number is 1 and that's a corner cell and
that's also a coordinates corner cell
this one has hook number two because the
hook only goes to the right there's two
cells in it this says hook number four
this has look number three
this has hook number what is it 6 1 2 3
4 5 6 and so the formula says that I
should take 7 times 6 down at that down
to 2 1 and divide by 6 times 4 times 2
times 1 times 3 times 1 times 1 and so
let's do that computation I'll cancel
the threes cancel the 4s cancel the twos
cancel the sixes and it looks like we
get 7 times 5 or 35 number of standard
young tableau of this shape is 35 you
asked a good question before if you
fixed a number of cells which ones are
the biggest which ones give you the
largest number it's an interesting and
rather difficult question that people do
know the answer to but it's too
complicated to talk about today this
video was filmed the mathematical
sciences Research Institute in that room
they're actually but the interview
didn't stop here if you'd like to go
deeper into the world of tableaus and
hook numbers including some details
about how to prove all this the
interview continues over at our second
channel
- it's actually something that's not
very well understood no one has really
explained satisfactorily why this method
should give the correct answer even
though the method itself is blatantly
false